[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Gabrielle Gontier
bonsoir bonsoir mathine Bruno Le Maire
le ministre de l'Économie a annoncé
auprès du quotidien les écho que l'État
viendrait en aide à l'entreprise Athos
fortement enettté oui Mathilde
l'entreprise informatique dont l'un des
laboratoires est au clés sous-bois
possède une dette de près de 5 milliards
d'euros un montant qui a augmenté en
raison des investissements risqués
d'Atos aujourd'hui l'entreprise n'arrive
pas à la rembours Bruno Le Maire a
déclaré je cite nous ne laisserons pas
tomber les activités industrielles
d'Atos qui représentent des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois l'état utilisera tous
les moyens à sa disposition pour
préserver les activités stratégiques et
alors pourquoi l'État est-il prêt à
venir au secours d'Atos et bien Mathilde
car le gouvernement veut éviter
l'investissement de partenaires
étrangers dans cette industrie française
atos est une entreprise stratégique de
l'économie et de la défense depuis 1997
elle est aussi un leader dans le domaine
de la cybersécurité et assurera la
sécurité informatique des Jeux
olympiques de Paris justement en parlant
des Jeux olympiques de Paris les 5084
médailles olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris 2024 ont été dévoilé par le comité
d'organisation et elle possède un petit
détail inattendus oui dessiné par le
joiler chôé et fabriqué par la Monnaie
de Paris les médailles comporteront un
authentique morceau de la tour effffel
côté face il y sera gravé la flamme
emblème des jeux le côté pile lui répond
à un cahier des charge du Comité
olympique on y retrouve la DESS de la
victoire Athéa nické le stade panathenaï
et l'Acropole mais spécialement pour
Paris 2024 une tour effffel figure aussi
en arrière-plan pour les médailles
paralympiques le joiler a choisi choisi
une vue en contrelongé sur sous la tour
effffel les mots Paris et 2024 sont
également écrits en braille en hommage
au français Louis braay on c'est pas
pour lancer des fleurs à la France mais
ces médailles elles sont très belles
sont plutôt jolies oui toujours en sport
la région Île-de-France veut soutenir la
rénovation énergétique de certains
équipements sportifs oui c'est ce qui a
été annoncé ce mardi 6 février à la
piscine Jean-François Henry de Chatou la
région a présenté un dispositif pour
financer les études thermiques à hauteur
de 50000 € pour les travaux jusqu'à
450000 € pour rappel la région bénéficie
de plus de 45000 45000 lieux de pratique
sportive parmi eux il y a des piscines
des patinoires ou encore des gymnases
des équipements vulnérables contenus de
l'augmentation du prix des énergies
parmi les projets soutenus par la région
l'installation de panneaux
photovoltaïques sur toiture alimentant
la piscine en électricité au total les
économies d'énergie enregistrées
seraient de l'ordre de 30 %. enfin on
termine avec une information trafic
attention demain soir c'est le début des
vacances scolaires pour la zone C les
routes risquent d'être plus encombrées
oui pour ce premier weekend vous l'avez
dit des vacances d'hiver les vacanciers
seront nombreux dans le sens des départ
des difficultés de circulation sont
attendues au départ de l'Île-de-France
ce vendredi il est conseillé de quitter
ou de traverser la région avant 14h à
contrario samedi et dimanche tous les
voyants sont au verts en Île-de-France
pour le moment bien merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
actualité qui vous a fait réagir
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news